and let me see if it's working okay what
up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest on the channel
kit what's up um he's been here a couple
times so
you're like a regular at this point i
have become a regular i think by the
third time i've become a regular
and i brought some some great guests
oh yeah you did you came in clutch yeah
i did i did
um before i start guys do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell as you guys know
if you have watched two or more of my
videos okay and you do not subscribe we
have beef okay beef people
i'm i'm like scary okay also so every
thursday friday and saturday this is the
live show that i do and it's at 9 00 p.m
so if you guys like this kind of format
where we just like talk about different
stuff going on in pop culture and like
relationships you guys should subscribe
also our sponsor today is cooking with
chris he offers completely custom made
meal plans guys i'm telling you i'm like
getting to be from like slim thick to
like skinny thick you know what i mean
i'm down 12 pounds in like a month
month-ish so yeah if you guys want like
a custom-made meal plan for you with
food you actually like click the link
it's in the description you'll like it i
swear i swear i promise
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay so today
we are talking about kim oh wait
actually sorry i got you excited going
um you should tell them where to find
you first oh yeah so hey my name's kit
uh instagram kit underscore is
underscore me and i've got my own
youtube channel that pearl will be we've
got an episode coming out in the next
week or so where she came into mind
spitting some interesting facts about
dayton um at stay slick with kit
yeah subscribe to his channel woohoo
it's really interesting i talk a lot in
that interview you did you do something
maybe too much so obviously
i'm watching some stuff back i was like
ooh
i'm like
they might come after her for this
give back women's rights what
look
i didn't mean it but
that's calm i don't think you said that
i think you said that on your own
channel too first so
yeah you've probably got support um okay
so today we're talking about kim and
kanye yeah so
i was a big kimye fan
why why because they were so he got the
the car full of roses what and he rented
out like a stadium to propose to her
yeah
and i just was like
i i thought they were like cute together
i mean that was nice those gestures were
nice but
i don't know
what's that i don't know
you know when it's like
you
you know when so many people want the
wedding but not the marriage
that's the vibe i got i was like they
want the whole grand gesture to show to
the world but then
like did they have like marriage
counseling or did they do any of that
before they broke up the first time or
no i think the problem was he was like
living in another state
okay yeah like i think
he like wanted to be in wyoming and she
wanted to be in california and they were
like doing like a distance marriage
okay they probably just wanted some
distance
they got two they're like i can only
handle this person in doses
um yeah i don't know they probably
should have done counseling or something
they built a lot together to like break
that up yeah they did
they did they became billionaires also
though as well like let's be honest like
he
he raised her from her profile
for being honest
like she was she was known
she was known as the girl who was having
sex with all these different celebrities
and then he wifed her up and then she
became like respectable but he was the
third guy to wife her up he was the
first too chris humphrey and then this
like i don't know who the first one is
that exactly was she married to ray
no she wasn't married to aj sure was she
i don't think she was that might have
been her first but i could be wrong i
thought rajo was just who she made the
tape with i know that for sure
i don't know
you're the biggest kim kanye fan you
tell me well i'm like kim kanye not
chris humphrey
[Laughter]
i don't think she might i don't think
she was married to aj oh maybe i could
be wrong but
but my point is like he he the previous
two i don't even know who they are so it
doesn't matter in the eyes of the public
but kanye's kanye yeah okay that's fair
do you know what i mean that's fair
so she kind of just so she kind of got
the cloud and ran a little bit
yeah i mean she already had clout but
she had like she had the clout that was
like the
brittany renner clout you know i mean
the kind of like oh she's known for
yeah just being with celebs pretty much
yeah but then if someone wifes her up
uh-huh
like she went from like ho to housewives
why do you okay why do you think he
white because kanye could have damn near
anybody yeah so why do you think he
picked kim
as a guy because i have a theory okay
that sometimes hoes get wiped wifed up
faster than prudes you did say you have
said this before
um why why would he have chosen her
i think
i think because they're probably as
crazy as each other to be honest i think
they're as crazy as each other
um
and let's be honest she like she was the
first this whole kind of
kim was the poster girl for
she set the curve the curvaceous beauty
standard
of like the current like modern era do
you know what i mean because before her
it was all about being slim like yeah
being skinny
like the model s one that was the only
beauty standard now every girl wants bob
wants a bum wants boobs and that's
because of her
so like i'm not saying he chose her to
be a trophy wife but like he was like
yeah i got that like the it girl
do you know what i mean yeah i think
that was the first attraction and then
you know she can have this crazy it's
just interesting because then his next
girlfriend was like a single mom too so
it was just interesting
julia fox
and yeah she was kind of wild too like
she got famous for doing like
like art
with drugs oh yeah like like heroin art
or something it was weird like some
weird edgy stuff and it's just
interesting it's like this guy can have
anyone and he picked like the girl with
the sex tape single mom
amber rose like why is that i mean amber
rose though like come on like every
every guy wanted to get amber rose
really yeah yeah is that hot i don't
like dogs
no i wouldn't say now but like five six
years ago she was like really popping no
like google her should why do you think
why do you think kanye picked kim
um why do i think yeah you said you had
a theory
oh i think sometimes
hoes get really good at making like the
art of a man like fall in love
you know what's crazy i i asked people
on the street i asked
what would you like oh the question you
gave me which was what which was um like
what would you pick great sex bad cook
oh a great head bad cook
oh but british people didn't know what
head was and i was like
i kept having to explain it so i
switched it to what
i did like they're like what and i was
like are you sure they were british were
they like because london is very
multicultural so were they were they
from a different country somewhere okay
okay but it was one too many times i
just switched it to such okay
all the guys
said we can order it
i mean if you oh yeah i mean you would
yeah you would
i would choose that
so um
i don't know i was like so would you
think about it like who's gonna be
better the hose
yeah no you're right
you're right that is true
i don't think it's right like all the
time but
i've seen some girls that i know
get around but they have guys in love
with them like all the time and i'm like
what the what do you think that they're
doing that the crews don't get
ah how do they do it how do they do it
you still haven't said what your theory
was as well why find their choices
because they're like
really good at certain skills
you think their sex game is just so on
point that guys are like wow she's the
one yeah or they're also like
i think the more like
they probably get more relationship
skills the more relationships you're in
and like at some point you know no not
long they might get better at getting
into them but not
not having longevity
i don't think any of them have rings so
you might be right
you're killing it or your friend's hose
no no no all of
there's them mix
that's so funny oh what was i going to
say uh what did you say before
um it's early 2000s
yeah yeah check out amber she was she
was like
for sure
would it be yeah even like yeah 2010
okay
i mean come on she's
come on she's gorgeous she's stunning
i just can't the short hair it's just
she looks great with it i she looks
great with it i mean there she literally
literally looks like
like a
sexed up marilyn monroe there he's just
not my female like if i had to pick a
girl it would be
i'd be megan good
megan good oh yeah
interesting she just divorced her
husband though
oh her yeah so she went from like a 10
to a 9.9 in my book
you still wiper that's the wi-fi
straight up what's that i'd risk it and
risk it for a biscuit what's the girl
from wolf of wall street i think she's
like um margot robbie yeah that's who i
would pick a dude that was so weird you
think that
like every one of my friends saying that
my all my girlfriends like different
variations of her
i don't know why it's weird i think she
just has like a perfect face it's so
symmetrical she is she
she's like visually stunning yeah she's
yeah i can't lie yeah yeah
she is oh
i had a really good point about what we
can say earlier what was your theory oh
yeah really good
i'm saying sorry it'll come to me i'm
making guys fall in love with like
certain stuff oh yeah well oh yeah okay
that would make sense if a guy was like
if he was the kind of guy who didn't get
any girls
so had
as far as like
his sexual experience it wasn't in
abundance
it makes sense that she comes in blows
his mind and he's like in love with her
because he's like oh my gosh like this
is the best thing since sliced bread
yeah but if a guy's like really
experienced
and he's got he's had sex with a lot of
girls with a lot of women
a girl might come along he might be like
well she's like the best one but that
the impact isn't that great
do you know what i mean because he's
he's got that level experience and kanye
obviously surely is the kind of guy who
has ran through a lot of girls
so for him to just fall in love with the
girl who gave him the best sex of his
life
where he would have had girls who gave
him amazing sex like i don't i don't buy
it i wonder what it is like
i don't know but i think maybe it was
like she was the it girl like she
okay she sent she set the trend
she set the trend which it's kind of
crazy how people can go from being like
so i mean on the surface like in love so
close yeah to being like in a public
falling out public breakup all that how
much how much of that do you think is
fueled by publicity incentive
um
i don't think the kardashians want that
publicity i think you're joking no she
has a sex tape
that's how she got famous like she's
done the worst [ __ ] publicly i i think
that the kardashians like
like this is the first guy they can't
control
that's what i think
i think every like tristan thompson they
could kind of control i think
yeah corey gamble they could like he's
not really gonna do [ __ ] but i think
do i think they want
kim to look like
she's not letting the father of her
children come to a birthday party or
like kind of make her look like bad for
putting her kids on tick tock
i don't think they want that publicity i
think they just can't thing is though i
i get that but it's hard because kim is
the poster girl for
social media influencer uh-huh so if she
was suddenly like no my kids will never
go on social media yeah like everyone be
like what the [ __ ] like you're the girl
you're the influencer chick yeah do you
know what i mean so like
it's kind of like you know what you said
before about adele losing the weight
like she was like the post child for the
larger pot artist and then she lost the
weight and everyone's like
that that's what's better for her but
then she's kind of lost the symbol of
what she used to represent
so i i think
it would be hard for her to deny her
kids to be even though i think she
should have it'd be hard for her to deny
it it is to do that so let's let's go
through a couple of the things that
happened yeah go on okay so the first
thing that happened yeah was can't kanye
doesn't want his ki his daughter on tick
tock i agree you agree 100
do you think
he
it's weird that he's saying he doesn't
want his daughter on tick-tock when
he was cool with his daughter like going
on stage with like a mic
and like performing
for his like clothing brand
i think because if it's safety of the
child isn't that like putting the kid i
think it's more
at least
on stage with him
he's in control of
how she comes across or what she's
putting out
but on tick tock
he's not so it
he's not uncon
he can't um
regulate what she puts out
whereas her coming on stage with him
it's a different kind of
vibe because especially on tick tock
like
a lot of
a lot of girls young girls
are
to some extent
set selling sexuality
and that's the last thing any father
wants for his daughter because her
coming on stage is being like oh she can
perform with me look how talented she is
but her being on tiktok like she's
putting some red like some weird makeup
on and what was the what was the quote
something like i know what now what was
it
um i don't remember actually i can look
it up uh what was it she said but she
was like that was more airing on setting
sexuality and she's how old is she like
seven or eight well i think okay because
i think of this from the like the
perspective
that's trash behavior the well i don't i
didn't i looked at the tick tock i
didn't think it was that bad it's too
far i've not seen it it just looked like
a kid with like a bunch of makeup on
like singing to a sound
but
like you never played like i played
around with makeup when i was a kid
yeah but were you like flaunting
yourself to like
everyone
with it no but this is this is what i
think of the equivalent go on so
you and i we have a child okay yeah boom
divorce awful i hate each other god do i
lose everything are you taking all my
[ __ ] off
should have signed that for you but so
i'm out here in my apartment i want the
kid
to like come on my youtube show
yeah that because that's what i do and
that's like a bonding time for the kid
yep do you i don't i don't really think
i tell you like i tell you to go to hell
if you said he can't be on my show but
so here's the thing though i think if
i'm because she's monitoring the tick
tock so if i'm monitoring it because she
the kim runs the account so i'll tell
you what it's about the it's about the
respect of him as a father giving
permission yeah so like i don't know
what it's like in the states but in this
country
if the parents aren't together
but one of the parents wants to take the
child on holiday they need permission
from the other parent otherwise they
legally can't do it legally they can't
do it because they could be running away
with the child right
so
and
and because of the potential dangers of
what social media can do and how
exposing it can be
i completely agree it should have the
same principle of okay if you've got a
minor
like you need permission from both
parents
for
for them to go on
and
kanye was not giving permission like he
was like no i disagree yet she did it
anyway
so
um
in that sense i'd be like nah i like
also the other thing i was going to say
when she came on stage with him
right
like
i don't think she was wearing makeup
like not like that
and one thing jordan peterson says
he was like wearing makeup is sexual
signaling yeah
so why is she wearing makeup why is she
sexual signaling on tick tock of course
he's going to be against that like i
said that's selling sexuality well
i
i do see that like that point of view i
do and i i could like i could understand
that but sometimes it just felt like a
little bit to me yeah in genuine and
more of like a control thing when like
magically like now when she's dating
pete you have a problem with this it's
just like but [ __ ] but so do you think
if they were still together he would be
fine with her being on tick-tock yeah
but was she on tick-tock when they were
just get together that's a good question
i don't know
probably not maybe otherwise there
wouldn't be this much heat would there
but he wasn't even there i thought
because i thought he was living in
wyoming
i don't know it didn't happen though no
you're right because okay here's the
thing right if they if if
if kanye and kim were together right
and
she was like oh yeah why don't what's
that kid's name blue no
that's daisy's north north right yeah
and kim was like on you know i want to
put north on tick tock whether and he
was like no i don't want you to because
they were together i think kim would
have respected his wishes but now
they're not together
she's not respecting his wishes which i
disagree because he's still the father
of the child yeah
but then that's kind of a sticky thing
in divorce because like
who gets to pick
is it always the flight who gets to pick
what like right i mean right now the
courts favor the mother right yeah so so
that's not necessarily fair but if we
were going to like reconstruct the court
system let's just say yep mom wants one
thing dad wants another it doesn't even
have to be tick-tock it could be where
they go to school where whatever yeah
how do you pick
well i would say
i would say um something like where do
they go to school it would it would just
make sense
that
so if the child's with the mother
to go to the school that is
um more convenient
for them like so if there's a school 10
minutes around the corner the father's
like no i want her to go to this one
which is two hours away that's silly
right but i think it's different when
it's like
something that can have
um
age restrictions on it you need
permission from both
i think so like so would you if kim said
i don't want my daughter on stage like i
don't think that's a good environment
for a child would you agree with that
would i agree like would you say like
then like you can't bring her on stage
yeah i would if she didn't want her on
stage yeah and he did yeah
and she was like no don't i'd like well
then you don't do it okay
i just like kim kardashian why do you
love her so much okay okay why do you
love this i like her for the same reason
i like donald trump i like her for the
same reason i like kylie jenner
which is what i like people
that
do things that everybody says that they
can't
so kim kardashian everyone called her a
hoe right and she said okay
call me a hoe no talent whatever
i'm gonna marry the greatest rapper of
all time get a proposal from him
and chris humphrey who's like i forgot
what he did but i didn't [ __ ] i didn't
even know who he is he's he did
something and so i was like i like
people that do something that everyone
says they can't
i respect that and then that the same
thing everyone says you have no talent
whatever okay whatever i'm going to
become a billionaire like that's some
boss [ __ ]
that's some boss [ __ ] i'll give you that
like i respect that her skim's line is
good i know a lot of girls that bought
it not me i'm cheaps and super chats
and it's the same thing with trump like
when he ran everyone thought it was a
joke in the u.s
honestly i respect that and then he ran
and he won like that's so cool kylie
just said he didn't just he didn't just
run like he won
[ __ ] me
and he beat out he beat out all the
other like republican candidates he beat
out
the bushes yeah but
establishment but here's the thing
though the reason the reason
trump
won
right
and i'm gonna get hate for this but i
don't give a [ __ ] okay
is because he was the most entertaining
oh yeah i agree because
i'm not a trump supporter i wouldn't
have been a trump supporter but any time
he was having a debate i was there
watching every minute because i'm like
what is this guy gonna say now have you
seen the video where scott adams is like
he knew trump was gonna one win because
that blonde chick from fox i forgot her
name oh oh
i know who talked she got fired
short hair
kelly
uh i know you're talking about something
yeah yeah something megan kelly yeah
that sounds right megan yeah yeah might
be megan kelly okay
but she asked him a question and she
said um
i think i know she said
you um like trump you you've called
women like pigs
this and in that moment he had two
options he could have said yeah i did
and like owned it then people don't like
him or no i didn't and people would just
look at the clip he's lying and he just
says only rosie o'donnell
[ __ ] legend and that was a [ __ ]
legend uh honestly like when that
happened i was like
thing is here's the thing though right
and this relates to comedy
did you see her reaction
megan kelly's
right she laughed
she laughed and then she stopped herself
from laughing which is one of the
brilliant things about comedy right it
goes coming because especially like do
you know who andrew schultz is
he's [ __ ] sick like he does he'll
make he'll joke about anything right but
like
the best thing about comedy is that when
it's good
even if you know you're not supposed to
you can't help it it's a natural human
response
so when he said that she cracked up and
she caught herself because she's like i
can't laugh at this
like i'm trying to
you know destroy this guy's reputation
that's the thing
about
he's very intelligent
he's very intelligent you can't put that
past him well scott adams talks about
it's like
being in the like
like he's not the smartest person in the
room but he's smart enough yeah and he's
not the funniest person in the room but
he's funny enough yeah he's not the best
businessman but he's like one of the
best and he's like those three
combinations got him elected yeah i
agree i do think i do think he's the
most um
like the kind of language he
and
you know what he's like
you know oh i've got this scientist he's
the best in the world oh this person
he's
he's he's the best car salesman he he
probably is the best car salesman in the
room like he could probably sell anyone
an old piece of [ __ ]
like he he really could he'd like it's
the best
it came out of michael jordan's ass
that's the limit of my donald trump
impression i'm very good
if you got a role playing donald trump
would you do it
[ __ ] yeah i want that i want that blonde
wig
on that blonde wig they're like can you
tan i'm like are you joking i'm already
dark enough
oh [ __ ] me oh my god okay wait
going going back to kim and kanye yeah
we were talking earlier yeah about how i
think that part of their problem
was that he was from like the hood of
chicago and she grew up with the silver
spoon i think that's really hard to do
what grew up with this over spain no no
like like two people date from such
different socioeconomic backgrounds i
think that's hard
yeah it's like it
depends on mindset
depends on mindset yeah like if you've
you're thinking about exceptions though
not the rule so i'm talking i'm like
talking about the rule i think like in
general that's hard i i agree but i
guess what i'm saying is he wouldn't
have got to his
okay and i said this earlier earlier
like people who outside of entertainers
and athletes
right because
those are probably the only avenues
where you can reach that level of
financial wealth without having
the mindset but other avenues like if
you're an entrepreneur or if you're
a business corporate person or you know
whatever it is
like you you can only reach that level
if you have that levels mindset so it's
like you know what one saying they say
is you know the poor stay poor because
they try to live like they're rich and
the rich stay rich because they live
like they're poor
right
so
that kind of mindset
you need that kind of mindset to elevate
you to that class you can't get into
that class unless you have that mindset
so if kanye has that level i grew up in
the middle class
i thought someone told me
i did not
oh sorry i was i stand corrected i don't
even know what middle class would like
what counts is he said he like grew up
in the hood but i could be wrong
but
but could you be in the hood and still
be middle class
like could you be lower middle class
south side of chicago that's like a
different i don't know is that like
chicago are like they're bad really
they're so like i would worse than
brooklyn i know brooklyn's bad or it
used to be really bad don't know new
york like that i wouldn't know okay
but yeah i think it's i think it's
mindset like you can't you can't get to
everyone unless you have that mindset
and he wouldn't have got there unless he
did have that mindset you know it's
crazy though kim still has got
pete davidson got tattoos of her
he's a [ __ ] idiot this girl this is
what i'm saying hoes can make dudes fall
in love i'll be honest though pete pete
davidson he was a loose cannon to begin
with like come on he was a loose cannon
do you not think he was a loose counter
no he was a little like do you think
kanye was going to get
kim i guess he probably could have
actually he probably he probably i mean
he was like publicly begging her to come
back with a girlfriend
you've had what
i've had a very similar situation
tonight yeah that's story time story
time to us
is this one of your fans
no no it was like
my my last boyfriend had a lot of
followers oh yeah you said i was saying
like like so he would go live and like
like
his fans would like
like
like beg for me that i don't know
oh oh when you guys broke up yeah
when i broke up with him it was like
like that's that's i see some of the
things kanye does and i'm like i know
this okay
like i know this game it didn't work on
you did it
but you don't care about what people
think
do i
you don't care about it so but kim
probably does do i ca i cared a little
bit i didn't enjoy like
my like
random people i don't know like texts
like
really
i'm gonna i'll tell you more about that
off camera that's so weird that's so
weird um but no i like i know that i'm
gonna read the super chats okay
kanye west donated
forget never get kim i want pearly now
yes
look
you've got way you've got way more class
than kim i don't care you actually do
well i don't think i would get kanye
then because he dated her in ambrose
yeah but that's because you don't move
like they do
no you're just not his type no that's
what i'm saying but he's not my type
either sure
could be a billionaire if it's short
it's overwhelming a little savage i mean
it it's not my fault
i just like i can't
that's what they'll always put in the
comments section they'll be like pearl
you get wiped up you just look at short
guys i'm like look i can't do it
why
i just don't
i just
like i don't find them attract i'm sorry
no but not even short guys like just
average height
it's a problem i just want them taller
than me
i know but you're 5 11.
my sister's gonna have this problem too
i know but it's hard because you're
literally like
it's just not attractive to you
yeah what to oh as a girl yeah
yeah but there are other things no there
are
like height is so important to you isn't
it like so
one physical
i don't think i go like some girls won't
date under like six three i think i'm
five eleven and a half who are these
ghosts oh my gosh i hear this all the
time like six two or higher or six four
or higher dude these girls only date
like nba players
i have a friend that dated a couple
really yeah okay but um is it one you've
had on this show
you're the american friend plead the
fifth
that's a yes um
but
no i mean like i'm friends with a lot of
tall girls though
yeah i hear that so
i don't know why i just don't
i don't know you know if i i find that
interesting stat today um
so
you know how in the states the number
the number of guys who are six foot and
above is like 15
so here in the uk is it worse no the
number of guys
who are six foot and above
under 25
it's about 30 percent
so it's great for me though so
if you want two guys i guess i'll have
to get hitched up you better come to the
uk look for them guys in their
20s i'm not under 25 anymore
your birthday was the other day yeah it
wasn't sunday yeah
um other super chat milwaukee hoods are
worse than chicago
i did
could be i don't i mean i wouldn't know
those areas so i lived in milwaukee it
was pretty bad too
okay how
are the court system as biased against
men
in the uk as they are in the u.s
yeah is that like a big thing here oh
yeah yeah it's it's more or less the
same we don't have alimony here i don't
know why that is still a thing over
there
why do you guys have why is that even
still a thing that makes no sense to me
i don't i don't get it either like why
do i get money for being married to you
that's what it is it's like there's no
kid yeah i don't even really understand
child support either
i get child yeah i get child support you
don't think child people should get
child support i have custody i don't
understand the extreme it's at today
when you say the extreme what do you
mean like girls are
taking drake's condoms to get
a bag and like the number one and the
reason that nba players go broke is
getting the wrong girl pregnant
because the way it works the way it
works in the u.s is like it goes off of
your income the year before
yeah that makes sense yeah so if you go
from like making a million to say 250
000 the next year you still have to pay
based on your old income yeah yeah and
it might take a while to get it changed
yeah so then you go broke
yeah and i i just don't understand like
why
like what are you paying for
and shouldn't it start with like being
50 50 like custody well no it's suppose
it's supposed to be
um the
so the the father
is supposed to the child should be
living a minimum of the highest
lifestyle for whatever parent is
providing that uh-huh so if the father
is living a very lavish lifestyle
the child who is his blood
should also be living an equivalent one
why
because it's his child
i don't think so that's why you don't
think it's his child
[Laughter]
because for the court it's not going to
the mother it's going to the charge but
obviously everyone knows like if a
woman's getting 10k a month 500 of that
is going to the chart the rest is on her
yeah
and so i don't know how we like prevent
that
because i mean i'm not like
i just think it's ridiculous
that like why if you get a kid by drake
why why do you get
such a big percentage of his income
that's nuts well well it's you don't get
a big percentage of the income i i've
heard i think it's big in illinois i i
heard
it's like uh 25 for each kid
or like
this could be wrong but i have a friend
who was like going going through this i
mean i wouldn't say 20 i'd be like yeah
friends
if i'm thinking for my child
yeah 20 20 of my income for my child
yeah but it's not going to the child
yeah but we we call it control million a
year she's 250 000.
if that's supposed to be going towards
my child then 100 yeah 100 percent like
whatever the child needs and i'm the
best of but obviously yeah well that's
it's not about how much it is it's how
do you regulate how do you make sure
that it's towards the child not the
mother but you can't
that's crazy to me but also as well
here's my argument like okay here's my
question to you do you think if divorce
happens that
as a general rule it should be
prioritized for the child to go to the
father
um i think it should start at 50 50.
okay i think
three days a week
i also think that you shouldn't be able
to move
hmm
i think that's not fair like if one
parent gets a job in another state you
made the kid in that state that's their
home that's where you guys agreed to
raise well unless you have permission
yeah right right permission yeah of
course because i've had this i've had
this um i've had this debate with
um other girls where
you know so i'm like oh justify
the alimony or like the extensive amount
of child support
and she's like well what if what if the
woman can't earn enough money to live
like well the child goes to the father
then
oh yeah
because if she can't provide for the
child
then the child should go to the parent
who can that makes sense
but then when we're like no like the
child should be with me even if i can't
provide for it and he should provide
where i like
which i'm a bit like um
i don't get that
okay i just don't
i don't know what like other than food
what are you paying for the rent the
food
yeah
but then at the same time
i don't know maybe maybe i can't say
this because i'm i'm not a father but at
the same time
if you can see your child on the
weekends
and your weekdays you have the freedom
and your weekdays
it's not a bad deal
it's not a bad deal
how do you look at it wouldn't you be
sad you don't get to see it like i said
maybe i don't know because i'm not a
father
so maybe i'd feel different oh free
babysitter
yeah it's a free bit but it's not free
because you're paying a lot more right
but i'm like well
when i am free i can see my child
instead of having to worry about my
child when i'm not free which i'm like
ah
maybe there's a you know there's another
side to this that we're kind of
neglecting you know it's also crazy that
women get so much lesser sentences for
the same crime it's very true like we
just kind of like batterize at the judge
they're like oh it's okay
what was a female judge probation
i think we all have this natural
instinct to protect girls and i think
girls kind of have it too oh girls have
a natural instinct guys have a natural
instrument to protect girls and girls
have a natural instinct to protect
themselves
but i understand that it's a it's an
evolutionary thing
because
well physically women are
the weaker sex on a general basis
so it was very important for them
their survival came more from
social skills and being selfish
in terms of looking out for their own
needs as opposed to
sacrificing fathers that's what men did
that's true but sometimes
it just irritates me because i think
that's why girls get away with so much
stuff
yeah i think it's it's starting to
change though yeah well especially with
the red pill yeah i think i think the
red pill is going to change a lot of
things oh yeah and men's rights and
that's starting to become more
mainstream oh 100 i mean purely because
of red people like less men when you get
married
yeah
that's true or maybe that's the courts
well and it's so
it sucks that it's such a big risk for
guys what marriage yeah because they
could
lose half their money yeah i i had to
have a conversation with my parents and
be like i don't know if i'll actually
ever get married i was like i'll have a
long time partner
but there may never be a wedding for you
to come to when it comes to me
oh my gosh my parents would kill me if i
ever said that
i think the same thing though sometimes
actually
time is different because
but i'm a woman so i probably i will but
yeah
well as soon as you accept a shorter guy
[Laughter]
all the guys in there they're like yeah
[ __ ] accept it
what are they thinking don't be like all
these other hoes
who like if you're not under six three i
don't even see you
i wouldn't make that card i'm 62. and
i'm like i thought i was tall enough
okay kit
go on am i getting some hate yeah
you'd be talking like a simp sometimes
he's an actual gentleman but where do
you draw the line what do you what do
you have to say to the people that think
you're a stamp
if only you knew that's what i'll say
[Music]
listen i let other people
i let the results feed for themselves
i'm a bit like um i'm not allowed you
know if i'm allowed to compliment
well because i'm complimenting pearl all
right [ __ ] it you can say that okay but
we're friends i'm allowed to compliment
my friend okay do you think that
um
men should be weary of a woman's past
because
well like for example with kim and kanye
like kanye clearly was not weary of her
past do you think well he also knew he
just didn't care yeah that's what i'm
saying
he white he wifed the thought like do
you if you were advising men
would you say
to like go digging see what see what
she's been up to uh
this is interesting it's interesting
because you coach women mostly right
yeah and you probably tell the girls
like do not
no i do not tell him anything no i don't
say that why what i kind of i say what
you you said to um amy when she came on
as in
you can choose what you want to do but
these are the potential consequences of
your actions as long as you understand
that
do you
so should a guy go digging
i mean digging sounds a bit
controlling or extensive not digging but
you think you should ask like who like
about her what she's done before or no
i would say if he if he has to ask
because if she's really out there he
would probably know but i guess that
depends on how you meet her doesn't it
because if you know her through social
circles you you probably know some of
her dirt
but if you met her online you probably
wouldn't know any
should he ask
because kim's public but stuff happens
between guys like kanye and girls like
kim all the time yeah
he's a here's the thing right i think
for guys
a lot of it is about respect
and if she did some thoughty [ __ ] but no
one knew
i don't i think that's
because if she's because it means that
respect
for her
is important which means it's going to
be important for him
but
if she was out there and she didn't care
who knew he's like oh i like her but
to everyone else this wouldn't look good
for me
so
i think it's how she handles her past
really because everyone's gonna have a
pass this is 2022. like
let's get real
interesting especially attractive girls
they're gonna they're gonna call you a
samp
i've never cared what people think
uh that's interesting because i would
tell my brother well would you rather
have a would you rather have a virgin
are you mad
you're silly if i only got any guy
from marriage any guy today
i'll say it on my chest any guy today
who wants a virgin
today
you clearly don't care about having
great sex clearly
i don't know because
you're
numbered from my experience numbers-wise
okay yeah a girl that's a virgin and
gets married you know what her
percentage chance of having a happy
marriage is it's probably higher it's
like a lot higher yeah but let me ask
you this
you know a guy who has sex with a virgin
do you know the chance of him having
great sex with her is
[Music]
i don't know it's not that high have you
had sex with a virgin i've had sex with
close to a virgin
when she was a virgin or she wasn't she
wasn't a virgin she she was very
sexually inexperienced and she was a
lovely person um it sounds like i'm
being hard she was a lovely person but i
it was the worst sex ever you can like
teach her
nah i'm not here for that man come on
now you better come
correct i'm joking
um i could but
i think if i was looking for marriage
and certainly down maybe it wouldn't
have been that much of a thing but i'm
just not there yet because for me like i
don't think sex is that big of a deal in
a relationship um kevin samuels was
talking about this
for a woman it's not for a guy it's
important
oh for a guy yeah because if we're gonna
call if we're not going to accept sex
from anywhere else
you're the sense we have better be
minimum satisfactory minimum i was
talking to this about some i was talking
to this about uh
a female friend was asking me for some
dating about oh this was yesterday last
night right and i was like when men and
women get into a relationship
we make different compromises
the woman's compromise is
i will not
even if a better option comes along
loyalty from me is me not leaving you
for that better option
the compromise men make is i will not
have sex with any other girl because we
know when guys are just looking for sex
their standards are much lower
so like a guy who's an a would easily
have sex with six seven or a five right
and he probably gets five and sixes
putting it on the plate for him
that's what his compromise is he's like
i will not have sex with these girls and
her compromise is i will not leave you
for a better option
which means if he's going to be
compromising on having sexual variety
which is instinctually what men
do want
the sex he is getting better be good
it doesn't have to be amazing it doesn't
have to be the best
but it has to be
satisfactory minimum
there was a guy
that i met at
a pickup conference okay a pickup
conference i went to a pickup conference
for a youtube video
okay yeah i like i wanted to see what
all the men were talking about you know
yeah
yeah um and so it was like john anthony
lifestyle
i had him on my channel just because i
had a lot of men's subscribers so i was
like
tell tell the boys how to get the
[ __ ] you know
i find this on his channel is so cringe
man i don't know um but he has um
he has a boot camp that he runs where
like guys pay thousands of dollars to go
learn how to get laid if you
want to make money as a dating coach
okay i that's just not my vibe i get it
but when i i'm about more than enough
it's like it's like
that's what i said but um when i went
through these guys think i'm a simple
they think i don't get girls so they um
at the at the pickup conference they
i asked um
he told me the best like one of the guys
that ran it not john anthony lifestyle
but he was like
basically a big man [ __ ] like i saw him
take home like a different girl every
single day he was he was good at what he
did i saw the results right yeah yeah
and um he told me the best sex he ever
had was with like a 45 year old
i
i believe that
[Laughter]
yeah
i believe it
oh my gosh
i mean you know
a few older women yeah and they know
what they're doing yeah
um and they were hot i showed you one
yeah
and she was hot i don't think guys it's
funny because the red pill is so big on
like age but i found it's more about
people just get fat when they're older
like if you stay in shape guys don't
seem to care as much if you're
attractive it doesn't matter how old you
are yeah yeah i do i feel like this
whole like
oh she's past 30 she's not attractive
i feel like that's matt that's massive
cap man like
if if an attractive if a footballer's
wife
he was in her 40s
and they're all like glammed up they're
all hot like you wouldn't say no like
you would choose a her over the average
22 year old like you're kidding yourself
tom brady's wife giselle whatever i
don't know what she looks like or she
look like is she hot so yeah show me oh
i'll show you
there's a bit too many there's a bit too
many absolutes in the red pill i think
something as a general some things are
kind of true but this girl
oh she's wow she's insane yeah she was
voted like most beautiful woman in the
world
i was still
oh
i would still take megan good over her
but yeah she really yeah i don't think
megan good said attractive she's
gorgeous she got the she got she got the
curves she got there is it the body or
the face everything she has
amazing eyes amazing yes guys let me
know in the chat amazing body do you
think megan good is that hot
she's so hot man
i think she's just not like you know
like margot robbie you're like oh sh do
you know why i'm not crazy about margot
robbie
this sounds so ah sounds so harsh
she's aesthetically very beautiful
she ain't got a booty though
she ain't she ain't got a booty and i'll
be honest i'll be honest nowadays
i'll take a booty
i like a booty and she ain't got it
that's i've heard that you know it's
weird i remember in like seventh grade
when all of a sudden ass was like a
thing or not seventh grade like
i don't know i said seventh grade like
16 17. it was like there was a switch in
the culture from like this the skinny
girls yeah and then all of a sudden that
ass song came out and it's like ass ass
that was a culture that was a cultural
icon because that that's kim kim k
facilitated that switch practically
she facilitated that
she really did the she she was the
poster okay i think her ass
is that good
because in my opinion it looks nice
yeah yeah it's
it's too much i like i like real [ __ ]
i like it real
and so
it's it's like it's like oh it would
make you look
but then i feel like
now i'll take a real one day actually i
was going to ask you that so it makes a
difference to a guy if it's like fake or
real well i've never felt a fake bomb
before what about fake boobs i have
i don't feel as nice i'll be honest it
doesn't matter i would i would i would
rather
i would rather small real boobs
than fake big ones really yeah that's so
easy
and
some small boots can be fun to play with
like that's so interesting and they're
just nicer to feel
boobs real boobs in general are just
nice to feel that's so interesting
because
like i feel like girls will spend so
much money getting this [ __ ] for guys
and when i talk to guys like
they don't even seem to like that stuff
or even like the heavy makeup and stuff
like the more i talk to guys the more
like my brother always tells me oh i
like that girl but she wears too much
makeup
that's true and it's interesting because
like the girls are doing it because they
think that's what the guy wants
yeah but no they're doing it because
it's what girls want
girls dress for girls i don't no they
don't that's what they do
you don't think that's true i don't
think that's true do you really think a
guy is going to notice what kind of
makeup you use
no but i think when they have their like
a low cut top they're not doing it so
the girls love
no i'm not saying they just okay there
are some things they're obviously going
to do for male attention
that's true it's not one or the other
but
the fine tuning of things
i think because guys we don't notice
that [ __ ]
yeah but sometimes guys think they like
the no makeup look
but yeah
no you guys they like it with an
attractive girl
no they like the light makeup look
that's a guy yeah yeah that's perfect
but
you accentuate what you already have
yeah yeah that's perfect but not the
heavy but i'm not i'm not good at makeup
that's not i don't really wear much
because that's why they love you it's
like because they know what they're
getting
because it's only happened a couple of
times
where i've
kind of maybe
gone home with a girl she had a full
face on oh no and then
in the morning i was like oh are you
doing different
yeah this was like
i started drinking and [ __ ] i don't
really drink that much now but i was
like i mean i'm drinking a coffee
well i was like if because if you're
sober you had because you can just see
it on people's faces the cake
i think
i think that just comes with experience
i'll be honest
oh really yeah
i think that comes with experience
okay i'm gonna read some more super
chats um
oh that's the simp one i saw another
couple i like that one that's my
favorite
um
a man if going to date an older woman
but marriage is something different
thank you black ops black ops you are a
great
um you donate a lot and i appreciate
that you need to start having nicknames
for your regular donators black ops um
i call sentience daddy yes you did
yes you did
because he sounds crazy dude he is daddy
he's giving you loads i'm like what are
you okay a man will date an older woman
but he will reconsider things when it
comes to marriage 100 percent older
woman is like for fun and experience
oh interesting how what's the oldest you
would date i would date no you would
marry so oh i would marry i know you
don't really want to get married but i'm
on the fence okay but if you did get
married what's the oldest you would go
you're 28 i'm 28. okay
you're right in the female epiphany
phase
it's not hitting my pride
it's not to hit my pride
have you noticed a difference in dating
from when you're 22 to now [ __ ] like is
it
is it night and day
not so much because
if i'm being completely honest like in
my adult life i've never really had a
problem getting
out getting women
but now it's
i'll be honest compared to where i was
like 21 22 it's a lot easier
do you have girls because you're you're
like like before they wouldn't they
wouldn't approach me they would like
send me signals
that maybe they're interested
i'm not saying i'm not saying get every
single girl but like now i feel like
more girl i get more signals from more
girls and it's got to a point now even a
few girls will actually make the first
move what are your dm's like are they
crazy
no they're not girls don't really no you
guys don't really dm me really yeah i
think only every now and again but oh
okay i figured because you're an actor
so you're like you're pretty big in
london right uh i'm not big
in my industry i'm known i'd say i'm
more like like people know because
they've seen my stuff for like you know
i'm getting cast for stuff and i'm
working with like big people which is
great
so i'm not like commercially known
dude like being successful in theater
specifically
doesn't always
mean like come on like anyone who goes
if they're if someone's like a theater
fan
then they probably would have seen me
before
and they become like they might follow
all my stuff
but it's not like like if you don't go
to the theater then you just wouldn't
know have you ever dated anyone famous
uh
yeah
like she's like a reality tv famous oh
who tell me i need to know
okay you probably don't know her
i can tell you what show she was on well
love island
she won one year
it was one year she won
she won her year so then isn't she
supposed to be in love if she won
it didn't last long
because she kind of had a thing after
she came out so oh really yeah and she's
in
oh i'm not going to say that
no tell me show me show me i won't tell
them you always say i won't show them
okay i'll show you
is she the hottest girl like ever
she's
pretty yeah she's pretty hot i can't lie
did you try to like date her or were you
like nah if i'm being honest like i knew
if i'm being honest i knew it wasn't
like we hung out like a few times and
stuff and like it was like a few casual
things but it wasn't
um
like because she was like had this huge
house and everything i knew that
financially i was nowhere near her
league like her house is like a 10
million dollar house you would get like
3 000
pounds per instance
like you should get i do
i do have a number i bumped into her
last year actually i'll be i'll be her
friend
and hang out in the 10 million dollar
house
uh maybe i should go into insta
yeah let me go into insta
guys stop trolling in the chat you all
are wild in today what are they saying
give me the head same troll because they
they use the same insults but like
different accounts
okay i think it's the same guy yeah why
what they say
they
i'll tell you later i'm not you can say
it no i don't mind no no it's not about
you it's about well it's about me and
you
that was it
oh my god she's so hot
how'd you meet her she dm you
no
i'll tell you how it happened
i'll
oh that's her boyfriend now
yeah he does not look like you at all
which is weird because what she said to
me you would be surprised why did she
say you were like her type
yeah okay i told you this before when i
was like you know when
like girls who are like like nines or
tens if they've ever come to me it's
because i'm their type to a t she's one
of them that's what she told me anyway
huh well apparently she there's always
exceptions girls make that's true
as always
interesting how'd you meet her
i'm really nosy so that's right
so when you um
so uh
when you're like in the west end show
you get prior you get perks part part of
the purchases you get private members
clubs
so i was at the private members club
with my cast i wasn't even meant to go
out that night
and i was in tino at the time
and
i was leaving and i was saying bye to
everyone i was going to go home
and i was in the
bar like really nice bar lounge or
whatever i was saying bye to one of my
friends
and then i remember seeing her walk past
i remember recognizing her face but i
couldn't remember what her name was and
i was i was as she was walking past i
was
clocking her she was clocking me but i
was thinking like oh i've seen your face
where is it but she was like looking at
me
then she went down and sat down with her
friends
and i kept looking at her and then she
waved
and i was like oh like remind me your
name again and she was like blah blah
blah i was like oh blah blah blah yeah
from blah blah blah
and then i was really interested because
i i've had a friend go on female friend
con i was really interested just like
what's it like yeah going on like and
watching it back and everything
so is it real are they really in love
yeah it's genuine when they're in there
okay yeah like they can be incentive but
like
because you see the progress do you know
what i mean
um so i remember going up to a talk and
saying like um oh
like what's it like going in
you know coming out and everything
and we're just doing general chitchat
and then i started to pick up on a few
signs like she put a hand on my arm i
handled my chest she was kind of like
very smiley and stuff so i was like oh i
was like maybe she's kind of feeling
this i was like so let me switch gears a
little bit so i was like
so she wasn't with the guy who she won
with
and i was like okay i was like so you
know what's your type and she goes
you're my type i was like oh [ __ ] oh
that's smooth i was like okay
so then we went to the bar got a couple
of shots had a bit of a dance
why'd the girl say this
anyway her friends were trying to
they were trying to leave one of her
friends was majorly trying to like
i'll be honest trying to like stop it
from happening
and she basically went to me she was
like oh you can come back to mine but we
can only cuddle
i was like all right cool was she lying
well i was like girls always say you
cannot cuddle
they just can't be like hey do you want
to come back to mine like it just sounds
bad you know what i mean
so i was all right cool so we went um so
we left
and then we went to mcdonald's um
and i remember i remember thinking like
we're a bit tipsy at this point but i
remember thinking like oh she's kind of
like famous and stuff i'm not gonna try
and be all over it but she was all over
me man like i remember wearing
mcdonald's and they're like a few girls
but like oh my gosh that's blah blah
blah and she was like kissing me and all
this [ __ ] and i was like drunk
like we were both tipsy yeah but it
wasn't like stupid drunk no no no no
like because we like like oh let's go
get some food yeah but like yo let's go
get some food she just did not care she
didn't give a [ __ ] and she had told me
that
um
that like
she's actually a really cool girl and
she told me that oh she's that kid
she hadn't been seen anyone [ __ ] a good
few months
um so she lied
i don't know i don't know
um and then we got food and then she
called an uber went back to hers
turns out she like lives around the
corner from my dad's place which is so
weird i think you're gonna say from your
place no from my dad's place i was
living up my dad's at the time
oh i was only at my dad's at the time
um
so i was like well this is it um really
nice area north london
got to her house i was like wow look at
her house bro like it's sick
and then she was like yeah all of this
is mine like i did it myself
[Music]
anyway and this was the weirdest thing
um so i went to the toilet and
um i went to leo and i was like like
this is nice whatever and i was like wow
the boys aren't going to believe this
and then when i came out she was like
just in her gown had removed all layers
of clothing but just in the game so she
was naked underneath
and she was like uh she was like oh why
don't we um she's like oh you're gonna
give me a cuddle and i was like yeah why
are we putting a movie on
obviously because
why would you not put a movie on when
you're about to cuddle
um
and then
we got into a bed right and i was expect
like in this big lavish house i was
expecting like a tv to come up or
anything no she got the movie on her
phone
and asked me to hold it so we're
spooning
and i'm holding she did not have a tv
she had a tv but not in her bedroom
vulva if you had 10 million dollar house
you know what i mean that's just
impractical
that
i was surprised that's that's the
biggest shock of this whole
story yeah i was surprised so i was like
so i'm holding
the phone while the film is playing yeah
and i'm like there's no [ __ ] way i'm
holding this phone for the entirety of
the film
um
and then we were spooning and then you
know one thing led to another and then
like did you like keep seeing her after
that
we hung only a few times after but she
was always flying like she was so busy
she was like a tv personality so she was
always doing public appearances here and
there and to be honest like
if i'm being honest i was like um
i think i'm just going to enjoy it for
what it is yeah and when it dies it dies
yeah i mean that's kind of what happened
is her new is her new boyfriend rich
he's like famous yeah always like
semi-famous it's like that's what they
always talk about hypergamy
exactly so i'm like i'm the guy that
she'd have fun with but probably
wouldn't choose long time oh my god
you're the you are the alpha in her
story
and what yeah right because the alpha's
the guy like shoot f she would [ __ ] but
like but not choose yeah not like you're
the foam you're the foam cannon guy
what's the phone cannon guy the phone
that's like you've never heard that
i think i've heard it recently but
that's what it means the foam cannon guy
is it's like one of women's mating
strategies oh the hot guy at the foam
cannon party where she doesn't see him
as boyfriend material but like she wants
to like when she thinks he's hot maybe
that's what it is so you're like the
foam cannon yeah in her story anyway
i'll take it i mean you saw her she's
hot she's so hot
oh my gosh
yeah um have you
ever had sex with someone famous my last
boyfriend was famous was he famous
yes was he
yeah
i mean not like tick-tock famous oh he
was tick-tock famous yeah he had 25
million followers oh that's huge
yeah that's what i was saying okay so
when i say i understand i wasn't just
making this like no believe it no i
thought he had like a few hundred
thousand which i'd be like oh he's known
on tick tock but he's no i love that i
met the demilios
if you know who they are
you're not in tick-tock
um
she has 120 million on tic tac and her
whole family like her sister's 60
million like
things are like i feel like
i feel like if you're famous on tick
tock that just makes you like famous for
the young generation but you're not
famous commercially
because i don't know anyone famous who's
on i don't know anyone famous from tick
tock
are you famous
[Music]
are you famous on tickets
i'm i'm not i have like 800 000 on tick
tock so i'm like decent but i wouldn't
is like
if you walk down now the high street
if you walk down the high street
how many people would rather when we
were with the demilios like they would
get recognized everywhere they're like
only by like young people though
they wouldn't get recognized by anyone
older than 30. no they
you'd be surprised like really yet you'd
be surprised
i mean it might be because their kids
know who they are probably that's what i
mean yeah yeah so it's like
yeah
yeah i don't know i feel like i feel
like once that generation becomes older
yeah then they become then they are
famous because most people probably know
who they are but until that happens i
don't haven't classes commercials
there's some people that are like one
hit wonders and there's some people that
like diversify into other yeah like
because the demilious went onto youtube
and they they did a really good job like
diversifying their fame actually oh yeah
yeah they're that was cool
i bet charlie puth too that was cool too
i don't know who that is really
your music i guess you do maybe would i
recognize his face
his music is he oh is he oh
wait did he go out with what's her name
did he go out with
yeah i know him yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
but
outside of that no i've had guys
i've had guys like slide into my dms
that were like what your dms like tell
the chat they're pretty like
dry to be honest how's it like i don't
get a ton i get some actually i'll show
you my message requests
yeah do it
um i don't get a lot i don't get a lot
of dm's you know like i get one dm every
six months
i don't know like that
it's very message request i'd love to be
a girl like for a week
oh
[Music]
oh yeah me my friend were just
oh that's a girl
oh she wanted me to not put her in a
video
oh i interviewed her on the street and
then they changed their mind later
i just took it out oh okay i didn't
respond though i hate i hate when people
do that like
yeah it's like
i honestly i've not had this in my life
like this much no but this is like can i
put it like i'll show you
like it's just different for a girl but
this feels like a dude that has no
profile picture so like oh i never tried
[ __ ] like that like
what am i going to do with this
can i ask you a question how how
seriously do you take a guy who slides
into your dms um
like if you like the look of him would
you actually give him a chance or would
you be like no i would you would yeah i
would
um i've never stood into a girl's dms
for like to try and date ever
really never
i feel like they're so weird really i've
slid into a guy's dms i feel like girls
are allowed to do that
no i told you because girls can't be
creepy
no i totally would if i if it was a guy
like i'm
i like i'm just oh you met him in real
life no that's different no i would if i
didn't know him and he had like a normal
looking the problem is most guys have
such weird profiles that like they
should do i have a weird person yeah let
me
let me look do i have a weird one i
think yours is normal but
i could like mine just shows my work
really
shows like what acting jobs and doing
what i've been casting that i would
think you were real because if they have
like two little followers i think
they're either not real they're hiding a
wife or a girlfriend
or like because i'm like why do you have
so little
yeah
it depends what asia but some guys make
like a second instagram
without a girlfriend that's true and
just yeah yeah that's such a good point
wow guys be out here putting in all the
that's a lot of effort for me man
that's such that's i'd rather just be
like yo no you have a normal instagram
no selfies
nah i hate when guys have selfie i don't
know why it doesn't make sense i take
selfies girls are allowed to have
selfies there's double standards we
accept it we accept it
yeah no you have a normal profile
i love you bb and kitty is spilling the
tea that's what we do over here all
right we spilled the tea
okay what else are you trying to think
of other questions about the kardashians
what else happened i'm keep getting off
i had a i had a really good question for
you about that let me see if there is if
i read the last super chat i can't
remember if i did
oh do a show about domestic discipline
relationships i don't know what that is
do you know what that is
no no i was looking at
something that somebody almost guessed
who i was talking about
her team's going to be like what the
[ __ ] did you say
they were blowing up my phone
i heard that it was a while ago it was
like three years ago if i get oh wow i
didn't it was a while ago it was before
like well i was in a relationship after
that so
um
you said you had a good question oh yeah
about kim
we were talking about you don't think
that she earned her success right
not that she didn't earn it she
she had access to resources the average
person doesn't have so and i don't mean
resources as in money like opportunities
the right people advising her the right
people to give her
the props like
so do you think if she was an average
joe
she like without
keeping up with the kardashians
average joe right without oj being her
grandfather or great uncle whatever it
is
do you think she would
even be a blip on the radar
um i think she'd make six six figures
still but i don't think she'd be like
brittany renner
do you know who that is
how do you know who she is no i do i
know she is yeah
um she dated colin kaepernick
yeah who she had the baby by what's his
name
the chat will know
the the basketball player yeah just
basketball players and she like
basically got famous for spilling how to
finesse them basically yeah i think she
would be one of those girls she'd be
like her no i
i think she'd have a business of some
sort
to be honest i think that would come
after
possibly because that's what happened
now like she got famous from
the whole rayjay thing yeah and then she
created different businesses because she
had the clout do you think she released
it on her own
the sex tape where do you think it was
leaked
it's very oh
i think it was leaked
by her mom
no i don't think i'm wrong you think it
so she didn't mean to put that out
though i don't i don't think she meant
to put it out okay but then her mom was
smart as be like ride this [ __ ] wave
yeah
but so on that
she wasn't like putting herself in a
situation on purpose you know she was
just reckless but also as well if i'm
being honest i feel like the whole
reason it was filmed especially by ray j
is because it was like oh i've it sounds
harsh but she was known as like the
athlete's bicycle like was she that bad
yo she got round would you really i
don't not know her dating she got round
kardashian so it was kind of like oh
like i'm with that girl who like has sex
with athletes do you know what i mean
yeah she was known as that girl oh wow
who has kim kardashian dated
[Music]
damon thomas for three years that was
the guy she married i think
yeah a music producer okay
ray j but this is dated this will be who
she's been seeing with this isn't like
who she just was like oh so how do i see
that she didn't nick cannon
you didn't even i didn't even know that
either
you could have been baby now mama number
12.
uh reggie bush oh i i recognize him
i feel let's just continue but yeah she
was no she was known for getting around
with like superstars like that's what
she was known for
and then the video came out and it was
like well now there's clear proof like
amongst their circles everyone knew she
was that chick okay
and then the video came out it's like
okay now everyone else knows
oh
i didn't know that part yeah i didn't
know she was with all the athletes and
stuff do you thought ray j was the only
like
well i thought because she was in a
relationship for three years before him
and then she was married again and then
married again so i was like seeing a
trend i didn't know she was i guess i
could have insinuated because chloe and
all of them kind of do
honestly i think
i keep coming back to britney renner but
i think kim k
the more we talk the mom like raj she's
a [ __ ]
era setter because she actually is not
only she's like the poster girl for
being an influencer but she was the
girl of
a normal girl
mm-hmm mixing in the top circles
purely because she's very attractive
do you know what i mean
like
because back in the day like the top
guys they'd only be with like the top
established models that was their thing
but now if you're a girl you've got
boobs and a bomb and you're happy to
post that online drake will slide into
your dms
dave will slide into your dms future
will like
has changed dating to be honest is like
girls that would be almost
more pure like they'd be in a small town
or something
can get the validation of a world
superstar in their dms if they're hot
enough 100 and then they know they're
that hot and then joey in her class poor
joey who's trying to get her attention
being like i got a hundred percent on my
math test
what do you think if you were
like i was thinking if i do you think
that's a blessing or a curse being that
hot it's a double-edged sword yeah it's
double-edged sword because
i think there's more prose than comes
than cons for her for sure she's a
billionaire off it
well yeah you know how to [ __ ] use it
but at the same time like the guys
you're going for
they're all gonna cheat on you
cam look like she's going for like so
she gets access to these guys but
they're all going to cheat on you
all of them
probably like what
you're going to even kanye was cheating
on her probably well he was the that i
forgot there was some famous singer that
he
that he hooked up with i was also
married and i can't remember her name
but
so it's kind of like a double-edged
sword if you can't get over that like
what do you do or you marry an average
guy
but your hypergamy's gonna get out of
control well not really because
or not the average guy but like you can
you don't have to
you don't have to marry a guy who is and
he was in the spotlight
but he can still be a high-earning man
so you can marry a guy who he's like
he's in the corporate world and he earns
do you think a corporate guy would date
kim kardashian no chance yeah
because he has class that's why yeah
it's very different he wouldn't marry
her he might date her but he wouldn't
marry her yeah for like short term yeah
people like yo just to say yo i dated
kim k for a bit yeah
well i think
pretty much covered everything i want to
talk about today yeah is there anything
else you want to bring up or bring up
not really um
should we look at the chat see what's
going on chat okay
i know you said you have to be up early
tomorrow i know i was getting i was
gonna give you two a quarter past eleven
two yeah so you've got twenty minutes
but that was good and man i think this
is it for the chats
the guy was so close
when she comes to him 90 done he can
teach her the final 10 percent
who's not oh are you talking about uh
when i said is that when i said when the
girl i didn't say that in this chat uh
so you know the guy said that oh
you're like oh could you teach her
in in the bedroom oh because i was like
on paper everything else was there
like everything the girl that you
yeah do you ever regret that or you're
like that was a good decision
i feel like i don't i'll be honest there
aren't many things i regret to be honest
i think um
[Music]
no
it was a good decision because i
because it sounds bad but it's like it
wasn't that
i i'm not saying it has to be the best
but it it just it wasn't good like it
just didn't match and i would not be
happy with that yeah no matter how
amazing everything else is unless i was
looking to have a sexist marriage then
here's what would have worked if i could
have had sex with other people
typical guy i would have married her on
the spot and she was the kind of girl
who would like
she
i mean
she probably would never have left
yeah because it sounds harsh but like
she was really rich she was really into
me man you break her heart i didn't
break her heart but she was really into
me how long you date her for about five
months okay
then you dumped her
i hate that word dump
i said we should be friends oh my god i
would be devastated and then she called
me for like the next two days
she begging you to change your mind no
she was just finding excuses to talk
oh my gosh as a guy
is that like is that is that you like
i feel like guys have a really hard time
dumping girls yeah yeah
uh well
except you you do it a lot is that your
thing
no i think i think it's
i shouldn't say this because she might
watch this i had a conversation recently
i had a conversation at some point not
that recently i had a conversation where
um
a girl who i was kind of seeing
she basically called me when she was
like
i just don't think i'm it for you
as in she was just like well if you
wanted me we would have
it would have happened as if we would
have gone to a relationship
and i was and i realized i was like
it's weird because
it's like almost i do feel that way
but then i can't say it to her like that
i have to be like no like i do you know
what i mean did you
did you disagree with her
i i said why do you think that
you're good
was that interesting okay why do you
think that yeah
that's what i said
and then she said it was because of and
if i'm being honest i did like say this
i was like it's not that i don't see
potential i'm just not at that stage yet
i was just honest yeah
but i was more like it's me it's not you
so you're you're half honest
i was honest because
there was potential but i just wasn't
feeling it right there well it's also
because you're young
yeah i'm just not rushing man yeah i'm
just not rushing yeah
i mean is it is it easy for you as a
girl to break up with guys because
you're so used to rejecting them
oh my gosh like there was no you
answered that i'll tell you this one
time used to rejecting guys you just
showed me your dms you ghost in them
that's a rejection
okay um
no i've only i've told you i've
there's one guy in college he rejected
me and then my last boyfriend i broke up
with
that those are the only guys you've ever
talked to regardless in terms of dating
potential ever no it's not
there would have been guys who
approached you and you're like you're
too short
yeah but it's not like it's not hard to
reject someone i don't know that well
there's guys that like we went on dates
for like a month and i was just like i
guess i do
you see
it's part of being a woman but like
those those there was this one guy who i
was dating
um i was kind of seeing in a casual way
like kind of recently and um
[Music]
and i basically said to us just like
look i think we're looking for different
things i don't think we should continue
anymore and she was just like oh no i
like she was like that's she was like
yeah i kind of figured but you know um
we
we should just carry on seeing each
other you know because like
her was not where she was i get huge
satisfaction from the physical side i
was like
okay but i don't but i don't want to be
trying to be like just using you for sex
i don't want you to feel like that
even though that sounds like the perfect
it's like every guy's probably what the
[ __ ] like she literally said she just
wants you to have sex with her and
that's it and you're like saying no but
i was just like i don't want you to feel
like i'm just using for sex and then she
was like no no no no like you know like
i really enjoy it blah blah blah all
this
so i was like
that's okay but then she was using sex
to get my attention
like it was like when we next had sex
then
she wasn't enjoying sex she was like do
i have his
attention and that i didn't like it so i
was just like
we should leave it
anyway it's got a very long story long
um
i try to like just say that i don't
think i don't want to do that blah blah
blah let's leave it and she wouldn't
stop texting me and i was trying to be
nice but then just got to a point where
i had to ghost her because she just
wouldn't stop texting me and i was like
i
i don't know how to communicate in a
nice way further that i don't want to
give any more energy to this
and she just wouldn't let me not so i
just had to go sir you block her i
didn't block her i just didn't i just
didn't respond like i had to it got to a
point i was like
ra like i don't like
i don't want to be that guy was this
recently
uh
like a couple of months ago oh okay
why'd you ask me i was just wondering
you're trying to get me in trouble
i'm nosy i don't think any
i don't think any girl watch this
[Music]
i i need to stop before i say something
i guess
i don't make you say anything
what are you doing to me
you're trying to sabotage my life no um
look girls we say one thing would mean
another so it's very confusing for matt
do you know that yes
see it's intentional
well it's more like we hope he changes
his mind
yeah
yeah and we don't but also as well she
was
she was at that age where
if she got pregnant by accident she'd
keep it
she was like 30. she was like 29 30. and
i was like oh really
i was like i don't want to play with
fire so i was like no i would always
keep it no matter what age
i don't i don't believe in that i know i
i i completely respect that
um
but yeah
yeah i was like nah
oh yeah i was like nah she's trying to
try she's trying to get a kid i'm not
saying she was but i was just like oh my
gosh she was like
you're such a dick
no but
[Music]
i've heard that from guys
i think i think i told you that about an
x of mine
i think i told you that before but i
i've heard that from other guys too oh
have you yeah that's like clearly it's a
tactic
clearly it's a tactic yeah i just wasn't
yeah no
i didn't want to risk it for a biscuit
[Music]
okay what are what are your final
thoughts
on
this
conversation that when like the second i
leave your place i'm gonna get a lot of
messages
[Music]
you think
do you think they're watching this no
they know what's that no
yeah you'll be fine i'll be fine there's
not enough viewers if i don't come back
you know why
no you know why no you're my pimp i know
i know i look healthy he gets me girls
to come here yeah i almost had three
girls come i've been dope yeah and i
told one not to come because i thought
we had too many people yeah and then the
other one bailed
you got a plan as i said i planned like
you know what we should do like tonight
we're supposed to have two girls they
both play do you know what you should do
yeah here's what you should do right you
should like invite six or seven girls
right and then choose three who you
think are most likely to come and then
be like oh i'm really sorry you can't
come in this show you can come the next
one because then it makes it seem
exclusive at the moment it looks like
you're like hey everyone come
so the girls don't value it oh you're
right does that make sense but if you're
like hey
i'll invite six and then your message
say hey really sorry but um we actually
don't have enough spaces but i'd love to
get you on next time they'd be like oh
it's a really hard time disincluding
people have a really hard time with it
well you need to get used to that if you
want this [ __ ] if you want them to be
more reliable
no you're right do you not tell them do
you not tell them like how many videos
you've got because that helps them you
could be my full-time pam
as long as i get commission commissions
you get the two dollars you know you
know you know you know you're you know
your daddy who gives you who donates i
want commission from that [ __ ]
if you're watching daddy just so you
know
i'm getting it i'm getting it
oh my god what are your final thoughts
on this conversation um king k kim k is
a boss ass [ __ ] i don't care whatever
anyone says my last question to you she
should not she should she should let
kanye be in the kid's life that's bogus
but
last question to you
would you want your son to marry someone
of course not
[Laughter]
of course i love kanye she's a badass
[ __ ]
i can like her
i can like girls and not want my son or
brothers to date them i guess you can i
respect the hustle i respect the grind i
think she's a hard worker
um do i think she's a great wife
no
do i think he's a good husband no that's
why they're so cute together yeah that's
why they can both be [ __ ] up together
okay guys um don't forget
to subscribe the channel and let me know
in the comments what topics you want us
to cover next week because i'm looking
at topics now for next week and tune in
tomorrow at nine because we're going to
be talking about that swimmer
that like
i forgot her name you know the trans
swimmer that just won the mcaas in the
women's division
oh yeah yeah that's what we're talking
about and i'm bringing on female
athletes to